problem with me is that i get beat by a
man over twice my size
and nobody else does anything about this
what is it let's reason about this one
i've never been exactly so you're a
habitual liar
no chairman you are a gaslighting
narcissist
you are wearing mascara and saying you
don't have a mental illness you
lunatic it's not mascara it's guy liner
sorry
wearing guyliner you are a guest
i've never attacked you dad i've never
tagged you in my life
and if you can't have the audacity right
now to turn into this camera and say
that's true
then i don't respect you you you already
said you don't respect him
you already said you don't respect him
all you do is make threats and you're a
victim nobody respects you stupid
they're saying the truth or i don't
respect you
you don't say anything that's fine but
i'm just telling you the truth i don't
respect you if you don't turn around
right now and say that's never happened
if you don't do that right now is he
blackmailing his dad for his respect
i don't want your respect you mentally
ill
i'm telling you the truth i don't
respect a person that can't have the you
have to
have a little bravery in you dad says
the guy who's terrified of his hus
a [ __ ] brother and won't move out of
the house but he needs to have bravery
because this is cowardice hello
dad oh you're just gonna he's just gonna
be
coward then that's what the whole family
is though i mean i get beat down
so
dad if you don't do that i'll put you on
youtube exactly non-con
when you call people you mentally bully
people when you when you
mentally bully i like how you look at me
with that squint in your eye
like i mean i just like to think about
how crazy an [ __ ] sherman schultz is
no no no no my friend i think that
earl schultz
every
single
well you know the rest
every
because he beats me and i hope someone
on that phone right now hears me
you beat me sherman you beat me oh earl
you beat me no
oh i'm so you the boxer you're the boxer
who's no you're not honest no that's the
the boxer well at least he's a boy
problem is that you're not honest and
you don't change your tone to suddenly
be honest when mom and dad are gone
you're gonna be hungry i
well when mom and dad are gone you're
gonna be
homeless live there you idiot if i
even survive that house after that yes
after the two and a half times he beat
you
how you're gonna survive the house
you're such a victim
poor baby the fourth time you beat me
i don't want to hear a word about this
you will never because you understand
that nobody likes you no one likes
germany all you do is no longer
no nobody likes earl shoats i like
sherman schultz
i am a fan of sherman schultz i
remember when the people that you moved
out and moved in with kicked you out
because
they said that you were psychotic and
this sherman dish this dish this video
is about to end too because
this this guy's getting btfo'd in this
[ __ ] hunt hyundai santa fe
they wanted nothing to do with you they
threw all of your [ __ ] out in the yard
his roommates his roommate's throwing
stuff out of the end
oh my god
holy [ __ ] i'm going overtime hey i'm
going over time streamlabs.com
live i'm we're finishing this sorry i
work hard for you guys
sherman what happened to you in
california what happened to you in
california
what happened to sherman in california
sherman he brought this big black car
what happened to earl in his mind are
that with him this big
uh yukon it's a yukon notice how he
didn't explain getting kicked out in his
stuff being in the yard notice how he
didn't explain that
he brings it home and within a month of
him being home it doesn't work anymore
i'll tell you what
cancer treatment for a year in that car
i took
jack to cancer treatment
i'd buy that for a dollar in this car
the car that now that doesn't work i
took jack
to cancer treatment yeah this sherman
guy
sure seems like the piece of [ __ ] that
earl's trying to make him out to be
i'd buy that for a dollar 10 to the
north 199 hahahahaha think you can
and shake some two bucks thank you
appreciate it
i kept that car because jack had cancer
you know
his car i had to take him
to ohio state for his cancer treatment
in the car
what does it have to do with the car
holy [ __ ] guys
we are our next level [ __ ] here now
what
i don't care about anybody's cancer spit
on him
that's what you do earl wow earl didn't
even
visit a family member who was dying of
cancer
holy [ __ ] earl what's wrong with you you
destroy
everything around you god this man is a
gaslighting narcissist and i don't want
to live in the same [ __ ] house
as him he beats me
he got beat the [ __ ] up with facts i
will and i'm not
and ended the video right there he got
beat up with facts
and he ended the video right there
okay sure let's play more we're going
late streamlabs.com stay wave live
earlier part mom saying girls were the
problem
here we go the man around
can see it except you okay mom
will you just tennis do you have a
problem yeah it's me that's a problem
for getting beat down
you have a problem bro
oh my god this mom's just trying to
watch her stories
this poor woman this poor poor woman i
feel for her
i feel for her explain what you're
saying
you have a problem what is the problem
you have a mental illness that makes you
believe you're a
you have a psychological problem explain
to me what my psychological no you're
damaged i guess
[Laughter]
i get beat down therefore i'm damaged by
a guy who
oh my god i want to punch you i don't
even met you and i want to punch you
right on the face
i want to punch you right in the face
and by the way it has nothing to do with
you being true
to that's you with being a [ __ ] dick
i want to punch you right in the face
beats women and i'm not going to i just
said i would like to but of course i
wouldn't because we live in society and
you can't do that to people dresses
or women women that's what i'm saying
oh you are a man i don't know what
happened to you but you're a man
obviously you were born a man yes i was
born male 1
you had a girlfriend not that many years
ago yeah that was uh
nine years ago obviously that has
nothing to do with
do women whispers exist do women with
exercises are not a woman i can tell you
are women with pieces of women
she's turning your tv up so thank you
for the footage
because you damaged yourself while going
on about wait what for hold on
because you damaged yourself while going
on about six
six six six i don't know
this poor woman this poor woman
did her best raising these children what
happened to you and we can't blame
single motherhood because the father's
there we saw the father in the car
i don't get i don't have some man but i
don't know what you want i'm an
attractive woman
no you're not and you're also not a
handsome man
you're ugly in both ends you [ __ ]
earl roll the truck
you're in a handsome man
there's nothing about feminine about you
oh
feminist well how feminine do you say
that
you're just like you talking like a red
nectar it sounds feminine to me
you dogging like yes there's feminine
rednecks look at that
listen to this god there's something so
wow look at he comes and he attacks the
skinhead son who beats me down a
six-foot skinhead son who beats me down
in front of you you are sick girl
i uh i'm putting this on youtube nobody
cares except for me
but thank you i want to say thank you
these parents seem like sweet people
i feel for them this is actually very
sad
talk crap in the chat and all but this
is a horror story of modern america
i agree i i will 100
agree this is very this is of course fun
to make fun of and stuff but i agree i
do feel bad for his parents
here's another video we're gonna keep
we're going folks going deep
he's filming his father while his
father's in his underwear by the way
oh you're fired
dad says you're fired since he won't pay
me a hundred dollars he owes me for
working my b
day weekend i was beat down
he was beat down again three time
remember we said three times
this is from february so this is this is
uh from from this year
you did not pay me the week that i got
beat down days before my birthday you
did not pay me
that man in that room sleeping in there
beat me down body slammed me
so wait a second you're you also your
financing and your money
comes from your father who gave you a
job so you don't even have your own job
felix we laugh to keep from crying i
agree felix barrow
i can't argue that for a dollar in front
of you and your wife
though you are the two people that
brought me in this world in that manner
and i
work in this house below minimum wage
and i don't think go get another job if
you don't like it
i work in this house guys this may be
the most hateable human being that's
ever lived
yes i do if i'm not going into a
conversation about oh 100
a week is not adequate pay for what that
work is
what work why don't you get another job
his dad also pays him oh my god
and he lets him live in the house for
free the dad lets him live in the house
for free
the dad lets him live in the house for
free and also give some money
this is absolutely unbelievable it's not
adequate
i'm not gonna have a conversation about
that i'm gonna tell you that you owe me
money and you know that you owe me money
he's the violent one
i'm already telling you i'm telling you
right now he's the violent one
i'm i i've seen people like this and not
even the
stuff he's the violent one he is
very aggressive hand gestures and these
are people that if you keep pushing and
they start grabbing you
i'm telling you earl is the violent one
in this family i'm
telling you without a shadow of a doubt
earl is a violent one
look look at the body language look how
quickly he gets the dad is being
calm very calm very chill
talking in here rage is coming out of
him
you owe me money for the week of january
12th
2019 that was all
last uh
why are you even breaking something up
that we agreed about whoa
whoa why are you bringing up something
that makes me look bad hold on i gotta
back up
the week of january 12th 2019
you spent 8 000
on his credit card
are you even breaking something up that
we agreed about why are you bringing up
something that makes me look bad in this
conversation i'm the victim here
i know you gave me your credit card and
i ran up the card but that's different
than this
before that we agreed it's on camera
it's on camera
okay it's on here now i'll i'll put it
get it out you're in denial eight
thousand dollars he put on his card and
he's the this earl
guy is ins oh
oh do i have oh am i gonna have fun with
you earl
we are gonna have fun with you earl
schultz
that's right it was on camera the
discussion well i haven't seen it on
camera
i don't know what you're talking about
now i don't know who you talk to
so am i officially fired see that
that's the these are the people that hit
people i'm telling you you could tell by
the
it's this rage inside of him i'm telling
you this is the violent guy i'm telling
you
then well yeah because i can't go on do
it
i'm not gonna do that anymore that was
about the
that was about last birthday look at the
hand motions look how calm his father is
versus him
last year where i got beat or i got
chased around and nearly beat down
by the same man in the same room in the
same house in front of addie
that's on camera okay this interaction's
on camera let me explain something daddy
bring your children last night he's
trying to talk
calmly is on camera as well i can do
i can do that all you do is
they need to keep this freak away from
the kids i agree i have to all you have
to do is pay me 100
a week as long as i'm working in this
house and that is that
pay me a hundred dollars a week as long
as i'm working in this house
even though i don't pay rent in this
house
that is all this is you're way ahead of
me
you're way ahead of me um look how calm
this father is subject
on the subject of money you're i mean
three thousand dollars
i are you bringing up the three thousand
dollars that has nothing to do with the
hundred dollars that you owe me don't
bring up the three thousand dollars on
the video because when i post this video
i want to make it seem like i'm the
victim
i'm the victim here okay earl is the
victim
you owe me that money it is said it is
stated it is simple it is not
deniable it is not debatable those three
thousand dollars
had to do with the uh birthday
christmas okay and it was agreed well
not like me it wasn't not it was agreed
not by me it wasn't it was agreed by you
and
3k 3k it was agreed do not play games
do you understand how infuriating that
is to be lied to both things on
i'd buy that for a dollar thank you
we've got a family member just like this
to a t
throws hand grenades into everyone's
life complete mooch and the scariest
part is
he believes everything he says yep
complete nightmare yep
you're absolutely right chris thank you
for the donation but you were absolutely
right
this is an act they are crazy and they
believe these things
yes i do because i am so glad this is so
tired of this
all this time look at this poor
look at this poor man he did his best
he did his best dad i'm getting beat in
your house by a
bigot who is over twice my size and
you're tired of me
i'm getting beat while i'm in a dress it
keeps happening
i'm either beat or chased i i have an
idea then
don't wear a dress or threatened
physically by a maniac
in your house where you you're the
maniac threatening people
[ __ ] maniac babysit tiny children
this is on camera right now and you're
just giving me a blank stare like but
dad you know it
i don't know what you're talking about
you don't know about me getting beat
down
that's never happened are you gonna say
that now because i have so much of this
on camera it's infuriating
okay we're all good do you want to see
your grandchildren in this house ever
again
are you threatening him are you
threatening him
you [ __ ] mooch peacey [ __ ]
are you threatening your dad not to see
the grandkids
over if there was something happening to
be a bruise or some proof
are you you [ __ ] living free in the
house you're asking for a hundred
dollars
because you have to help around the
house when you should be paying rent
you piece of [ __ ] human garbage and
you run up 3
000 on this dude's credit card you're
[ __ ]
garbage you're a
piece of [ __ ] i would say human
garbage but you're not
you're a piece of some sort of
animalistic
feces that's what you are your animal
feces
you're not even you don't you don't live
up to the term of being human
so put all the way wigs and the dresses
on you want you're just gonna be
a piece of [ __ ] a literal piece of [ __ ]
in a wig in a dress you [ __ ] [ __ ]
putting your parents through this
how [ __ ] dare you can you play this
back to people
and show them what you're like
they know this look on my face because
they already know it
you have no people you had 35
subscribers you know what i do
you know what you're going to do is
you're going to change the subject like
an [ __ ]
call them an [ __ ] oh yeah like you
would have a solution to this if you are
my size
getting yeah you leave move out
beat down by a man over twice size and
add psoriasis all over your body
oh yeah like you would have a better
solution i probably would
no you'd be a dumbass is what okay well
uh
then i'll be like yeah all right look
how calm this father is
now dad you wouldn't be different well i
wouldn't be any different than you
oh my god look i'm not even thinking
straight right now because these
arguments get so asinine
they get completely ridiculous because
you twist and twist and twist you turn
because he uses things that you've done
against you and you can't live up with
your own you can't live
uh with your own mistakes being thrown
into your face because it destroys your
entire argument is that what it is early
everything around a person you're
narcissistic and you're a bigot like
your son
like your son that beats me and i'm done
with your [ __ ]
because then leave no one should be
going without getting
then leave that
does that mean you're going to leave did
you hear the dad
does that mean you're going to leave the
birthday you dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm so
tired of this [ __ ]
i should not be in full dress with
makeup
getting body slammed and beat and almost
my arm ripped from socket
almost like that almost happened this
man body slammed me in front of the bunk
mom just says oh he's just hugging you
and he's just being very snide about it
dad that's [ __ ]
you have no heart in your soul if you
freaking
you have no heart in your soul act like
that ain't a problem
for you not just me anymore so are you
moving out
it's a problem and you so are you moving
out at least
pay me the hundred dollars that you owe
me pay me
now because i'm a victim for the week
that i i
worked that week and the night before i
was to be paid i got
beat they were down by a man who's like
over 200 pounds or something
okay that's [ __ ] up me five hours a
week to do that that's twenty dollars
now dad i'm not gonna have a [ __ ]
discussion about
money when you owe it to me
thank you thank you
uh did you not say anything i want to
let me check
let me check stop it it's below minimum
wage
no one would disagree with that but
you're not paying rent you stupid piece
of [ __ ]
uh soft gg says you don't give it to him
he does
you got to give it to him he does act
like a [ __ ] agreed yeah he does act
like a [ __ ] your rights up a hundred
percent
for you because you have to because it's
your money that's the only thing in your
mind it's at your money
dad i work for what i get paid or more
that's the thing i get or then leave
i pay i work at least as much as i get
paid that's
horrible when you have psoriasis all
over the body
you're getting beat down when you're
getting humiliated by your mother and
your father about the clothes that you
wear
when you're being completely ignored by
your sister because she's bizarre kids
like that like brain you're being
ignored
by your sister because she's
busy with her kids
you're being ignored by your sister
because she's busy
with her kids his house isn't gonna it
like it could make the problem way worse
you guys are all ignorant in this
situation and you know it
it's on camera it's on camera nothing
has been on camera that has been
incriminating
with these people nothing everything's
been cameras been you
absolutely being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you have no rebuttal you have no
rebuttal you have nothing
you don't let him talk okay so you're
fired
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i'm not getting paid i barely get paid
you won't get paid if you're fired i
mean i was like a dick
suck a dick [ __ ]